Привет! Я Даниил. Рад, что вы здесь. Давайте немного познакомимся. Коротко обо мне. Я продуктовый
дизайнер и веб-разработчик. Последние несколько лет плотно работаю на стыке дизайна, разработки и
искусственного интеллекта. Какая-нибудь генерация картинок — это только маленькая часть всего
процесса. Думаю, вы это уже понимаете. Основное — это, конечно, исследование, проектирование,
прототипирование. И искусственный интеллект я использую как рабочий инструмент на каждом
из этапов. Программа про то же, как вы уже сейчас можете работать быстрее, брать дороже и заниматься
более интересными задачами вместо рутины. Модуль называется AI Strategist — это первый модуль. Здесь мы
займёмся тем, чем обычно занимается Senior Product Manager. Исследование рынка, сбор требований,
тестирование гипотез, продуктовая документация. Делать мы это все будем с помощью и агентов. Чуть
позже объясню, почему именно агентов, а не каких-нибудь чатиков. К концу модуля у вас будет набор артефактов по
вашему проекту. Бриф, конкурентный анализ, персоны, результаты тестирований и готовый PRD. С этими
документами вы приходите к клиенту или руководителю и говорите на языке бизнеса, а не просто пикселей,
картинок и каких-то абстрактных представлений. Как обычно выглядит работа дизайнера? Приходит
с задачей от Product Manager или напрямую от клиента и звучит примерно так: «Нужен редизайн личного кабинета? Сделай
современно и удобно. Референсы, notion и linear». Или, например, в сдэк у меня была задача: «Сделай на
главный в личном кабинете для предпринимателей дашборд». Какой? Почему дашборд? Зачем? Никто
не знает. Просто взбрело в голову. Три строчки, ноль контекста, кто пользователь, какие задачи решает,
какие ограничения, какие метрики успеха. Ничего этого нет. Поэтому дизайнер идет копать,
тратит кучу времени или еще хуже говорит: «Ну ладно, разберемся по ходу» и через неделю показывает
макеты и слышит: «Мы имели в виду совсем другое». Таким образом задача начинает крутиться на одном и том
же месте, что-то меняется, дорабатывается, но остаются ненужные артефакты итерации, тратится время,
а результат кажется все равно не тем, что хотелось бы. И как это может выглядеть иначе? Та же задача,
редизайн личного кабинета, но вместо того, чтобы открывать фигмы или вручную копаться в интернете,
мы сначала с помощью ИИ делаем этот список задач. Первый - проводим структурированный брифинг,
через 10 минут у нас уже документ на две страницы вместо трех каких-то строчек. Второе - запускаем
исследование конкурентов, через полчаса мы знаем, что делают 5 ближайших продуктов, где у них сильные,
где слабые места. Затем создаем детализированных персон пользователей с реальными сценариями,
мотивацией и раздражителями, а не просто Маша 28 лет любит кофе. И четвертый этап - мы тестируем
гипотезы на этих персонах для того, как нарисовали хоть один экран. Ну и в конечном итоге последний этап -
мы собираем PRD - документ, где зафиксированы цели, метрики, юзер сториз, критерии успеха,
то есть проектная документация. И только после этого открываем фигму, но теперь уже точно знаем, что мы рисуем,
зачем и как нам двигаться, по каким этапам, что для нас является ключевым. Поэтому в таком случае вы уже
приходите к клиенту с данными, с обоснованием, с проверенным решением, вместо "вот классный макетик,
нравится тебе", мы ему уже говорим. И такого же качества мы обратку получаем, где-то что-то править,
чисто по ощущениям. Мы же вместо этого говорим: "Вот проблема, вот что мы выяснили, вот почему решение такое,
почему оно таким должно быть". И если раньше для этого нужен был годами набитый опыт или аналитик с
продактом в команде, сейчас значительную часть этой работы можно делать с помощью искусственного
интеллекта. И когда я говорю с помощью искусственного интеллекта, я не имею ввиду закинуть промпт в чат GPT.
Вы наверняка пробовали, задаёшь вопрос, получаешь текст, иногда полезно, иногда вода, но основная
проблема даже не в качестве, а в том, что каждый запрос, но это практически с чистого листа разговор.
Контекстное окно там маленькое, он забывает, о чём вы говорили несколько запросов назад, и ты не
знаешь, что он помнит, а что нет. Листать вверх, копировать, вставлять, будет много информации. В общем,
это бесполезно. Мы будем работать иначе через ИЕ агентов. Почему через ИЕ агентов? Агент - это
совершенно другой способ взаимодействия с моделью. Не вопрос-ответ, закрыл вкладку. Агент работает в
среде, у него есть файлы проекта, результаты предыдущих шагов, инструкции. Провели брифинг,
результат сохранился. Сделали конкурентный анализ, он также лёг рядом. Создали персоны, агент их видит.
И, соответственно, в дальнейшем любую из этих артефактов вы можете дорабатывать на основе всей общей
картины. И когда вы попросите собрать PRD, он возьмёт всё, что вы наработали за модуль и соберёт
документ из ваших данных, а не просто придумает их с нуля. Я думаю, в Figma вы тоже не рисуете каждый
экран в отдельном файле. Работайте в одном пространстве, с одной компонентной базой,
стилями и так далее. С агентами - то же самое, только для исследовательской и продуктовой работы. На
самом деле есть огромное количество ещё применений агентов. Здесь в первом модуле мы будем
использовать агентов для брифинга, исследований, тестирования и документации. В четвёртом модуле
мы дойдём до более сложных сценариев. Агенты будут собирать прототипы, сами исправлять
найденные проблемы, ну и в принципе решать задачи конкретного бизнеса, а не просто там
подготавливать какие-то тексты для нас. Но сначала база и начнётся она здесь уже в этом уроке. Что
нас вообще ждёт в модуле? В модуле всего четыре блока. Каждый блок - это один этап продуктовой
работы. Первый блок - это сбор требований. Техника рекурсивного брифинга. Агент задаёт
вам вопросы раунд за раундом и из трёх строчек вводных получается полноценный бриф. Покажу этот
метод, потом мы посмотрим, как он работает на практике. Второй блок - это исследования. Deep Research,
конкурентный анализ и я и аудит существующего продукта. Всё это мы посмотрим. Третий блок - тестирование
гипотез. Это синтетические персоны, юзабилити-тесты, симуляции интервью. Мы проверяем идеи до начала
отрисовки. Четвёртый блок - это документация и упаковка. Собираем всё в PRD. Агент берёт
артефакты, которые вы создали за весь модуль и генерирует готовый документ. То есть логика у нас тут
сквозная. Каждый блок строится на результатах предыдущего: бриф, исследование, тестирование, документ.
Агент ведёт весь этот процесс вместе с вами и накапливает контекст от урока к уроку. Мы не
переходим между чатами, ничего не забывается. У нас среда, которая только совершенствуется и
совершенствуется. После каждого урока будет домашка, всегда на вашем собственном проекте. К концу
модуля у вас будет готовый набор документов по реальной задаче. А пока давайте начнём с того,
что я покажу, как создать агентскую среду. То место, где мы будем работать в рамках этого модуля.
Итак, на выбор у нас есть две среды для всего этого. Первый - это антигравити. Я советую именно его.
И второй - OpenCode. Антигравити платный, но купить подписку сейчас можно на внешних ресурсах. На
платимаркете, например, за 1000 рублей на полгода. И здесь вам доступны будут самые передовые модели.
Это Gemini 3.1 Pro и Cloud Opus. То есть за 1000 рублей на полгода, плюс ещё там 2 терабайта хранилища на
гугле. В общем, практически даром. Ссылка, где взять, будет в описании под уроком. Если же платить,
ну прям никак не хочется, можно воспользоваться OpenCode. Чуть позже о нём поговорим. Здесь, я думаю,
всё понятно. Мы открыли антигравити. Справа у нас панель, в которой мы общаемся с нашим
и агентом. Давайте создадим среду, в которой мы будем работать в рамках этого модуля. Нажимаем OpenFolder и
здесь вот, например, в папочке агенты, я создам новую папку с средой для урока. Назову её
АПП-курс. Всё. Создал папку. Здесь у нас пока ничего нет. На самом деле, мы уже можем начинать с ним работать. Он будет тут создавать
файлы и так далее. Но для начала нам нужно его правильно настроить. Для этого нам нужны файлики. Вообще, только один в данном случае,
который называется GeminiMD. Этот файл будет прикреплён в описании к уроку. Просто закидываем его сюда. Что в этом файле? Нам вообще не
не обязательно разбираться, как он работает. Считать, что тут. Ну, я вкратце объясню, если тебе интересно. Здесь описана трёхуровневая архитектура,
по которой должен работать наш и агент. Первое - это директивы, то есть конкретные указания, которые будут переиспользоваться, которые раз за разом будет выполнять агент. Это какая-то общая информация, которая описывает поведение агента, то, как он должен действовать.
Второе - это оркестрация. Это уже те файлы, которые добавляем мы, то, с чем он работает, то, что мы правим. Третий уровень - это экзекьюшн или выполнение, то есть то, где он создаёт скрипты, конкретные артефакты и так далее. Нам со всем этим ознакомливаться не обязательно. Мы можем просто перетянуть в чатик, выбрать модель Gemini 3.1 Pro. На самом деле, лучше всего работает Opus 4.6, Gemini 3.1 Pro работает быстрее, поэтому мы воспользуемся ей. У нас тут задача несложная.
Попросим развернуть среду. Какие папки, где создавать, что это должно быть. Закидываем ему и немного ждём. Он здесь изучает этот файл, думает, мы можем пробежаться, что он делает. Выполнил терминальную команду, создал файлы.
Все. Вот у нас есть директивы, экзекьюшн, то, что описано у нас было в этом документе. По сути, уже готова наша среда. Мы можем в ней продолжать работать, ставить ему задачи и так далее. В целом, для настройки первичной этого достаточно.
Если же ты совершенно не хочешь покупать подписку, хочешь всё делать бесплатно, пожалуйста, есть OpenCode. Ссылка, где скачать, купить Antigravity, где скачать OpenCode, будет также под уроком.
Итак, OpenCode. Мы открываем, у нас приветственное окно. Нам нужно здесь нажать «Открыть проект». Точно так же создаём новую папку, открываем её и в этом проекте действуем.
Здесь нажимаем на иконку с папкой и видим все наши файлы в этом пространстве. Здесь окна мы можем точно так же закидываем файл.
В этот раз уже это будет Big Pickle MD, потому что здесь у нас модель называется Big Pickle бесплатная. Она работает достаточно хорошо.
Пользоваться можно бесплатно. По сути, весь тот же самый Flow пройти. Но ты должен понимать, что бесплатное будет работать хуже. Для того, чтобы, в принципе, с подходом ознакомиться, будет достаточно и бесплатного вот этого OpenCode.
Но каких-то заоблачных результатов, конечно, ждать от него не стоит. Я думаю, что лучше сразу приучать себя к инструменту хорошему, с которым ты будешь дальше идти уже в профессиональной деятельности.
Итак, на этом всё с вводной частью. В следующем уроке мы переходим к делу, разбираем метод рекурсивного брифинга.
В качестве домашнего задания тебе нужно будет сделать всё то же самое, то есть либо в OpenCode, либо в Antigravity, развернуть свою среду и просто скинуть скрин, что у тебя вот эти папочки появились, что среда твоя полностью готова.
Я думаю, мы сегодня всё разобрали, ничего сложного нет. Увидимся в следующем уроке. До встречи!